we've said many times Donald Trump
doesn't appear to ever show empathy for
anyone if I were the victim of a tragedy
the last person I would want comforting
me would be Donald Trump and there's
incredible new video of Donald Trump
learning that the family of an 8 year
old boy was killed and Trump shows no
emotion whatsoever and focuses on the
cartoonish nature of an eight-year-old
getting sucked up by a tornado
Trump having almost no reaction
whatsoever that the to the news that the
boy's family was killed the kid is now
an orphan his parents were killed his
sister was killed
but Trump continuing to do the cyclone
motion with his hand in video I will
show you and talk about just the
remarkable nature of somebody being
sucked up by a tornado
this happened in Tennessee which had
horrible tornado last week Trump flew
down to meet some of the families
imagine that imagine suffering tragedy
and Trump shows up to greet you and come
for you Trump stood in front of houses
that were totally destroyed by the
tornadoes and just fixated on the story
of this one kid and again Trump showing
no emotion whatsoever during the video
you'll see Trump fixated on the kid
being picked up by the tornado asks what
happened to the parents is told the
parents were killed the sister was
killed and he says oh okay well the
tornado just sucked the kid up and it
seems almost like the family dying is an
irrelevant aside oh the family was
killed the kid was sucked up and Trump
doing this cyclone motion with his hand
take a look there was one case though I
heard a young man was a eight year old
boy was ripped out flown to a certain
area and dropped off at the street two
or three blocks away
and they found him walking and he said I
just flew in the air and he was walking
down the street two blocks away from
himself and how did this parents do we
don't we're not sure exactly how they
turn
[Music]
so it took him and he said I was carried
by the air away from my house and his
parents were killed and the system so
we're gonna go see some of the folks a
kid was sucked into a tornado flung down
the street his family died and Trump is
obsessed with the tornado itself sucking
the kid up and seems completely unmoved
by the death of the entire family he's
talking about it like some kind of
novelty he keeps making that cyclonic
twirling motion with his hands after
being told everybody died but kids
family is dead and Trump no condolences
it's not even sure it's not even clear
you know if if some reaction even if he
doesn't know what to say that shows some
empathy acknowledged the tragic sadness
of a kid who's now an orphan after being
thrown around by a tornado and again I
got emails from from people saying David
this is video that proves Trump's a bad
person or David this is video that
proves Trump has dementia this is
cognitive decline I don't know guys I
don't know what it is I can't figure it
out lack of empathy seems to be clearly
a part of it it's really really bad
though and it reminded me of when a baby
survived the mass shooting in Texas
while Trump was president the entire
babies family was killed this was an
orphaned baby and Trump staged a picture
with the baby after having the baby
brought back to the hospital with
Melania holding the baby and Trump
grinning ear-to-ear with a thumbs up the
most fabricated photo op using a baby as
a complete and total prop and again
showing the total lack of empathy
the tornado video shows the exact same
thing it's just a disgusting terrible
person there's nothing new there using
an orphaned infant as a prop later just
retelling over and over while doing the
cyclone motion with his hand about a kid
sucked up by a tornado and at this point
if you're appalled by Trump's behavior
you
surprised by Trump's behavior you're not
paying attention what we should be
shocked disgusted and appalled by is
that 40% of our neighbors here in the
United States statistically still
condone this
they still support this and probably
close to half of the population that
plans to vote in November is going to
vote for four more years of this that's
where we should be focusing our
discussed at this point because it is
disgusting
we will likely have the video we played
and more coverage of this on the David
Pakman show
instagram page at david pakman show
follow our page there we will take a
quick break and be right back after this
one of our sponsors today is a game
called lawgivers a turn based political
simulation game for PC iOS and Android
if you've ever wanted to start a
political party or run for office or
shape the destiny of our country here's
your chance I've been having a ton of
fun with the game you do get to
experience legislative democracy up
close and the dynamics of the game are
really impressive you make election
promises to your constituents it's up to
you whether you keep those promises when
you're in office all of the laws you
pass affect your country's happiness and
safety health care environment you can
abolish laws that are already in place
you can ratify the Constitution you
decide if you want the government to be
a healthy democracy or authoritarian
tyranny you can be corrupt and take
bribes political assassinations are part
of the game it's nuts actually it's a
really good time it doesn't get old
because you'll never play it the same
way twice this is not some cheesy
free-to-play game it's very clear that a
lot of time went into the development it
has very positive reviews on Steam and
in the App Store's four and a half stars
or higher on all platforms go to david
pakman.com slash game which is where you
can watch the trailer download the game
for Steam iOS and Android
that's david pakman.com slash game